[Musique]
les textes dérangeants
3 si la perspective souvenez-vous il ya
quelques mois presque un an on avait
fait plus que mange plus que c'est bon
il ya presque un an on avait fait un
seul résident qui s'appelait je crois
confuse et une perspective je dis je
crois mais en vrai je suis allé vérifier
bah ouais dans lequel il y avait toutes
sortes de vidéos et d'image qui trompait
notre cerveau comment hostile ce qu'il
faut avec les jeux de perspective c'est
que c'est intemporel mon gars ça fait
des années et des années des années que
je vois tous les ans plein de tweets ou
de postes qui ont une portée phénoménal
parce que c'est toujours surprenant ça
intéresse tout le monde en fait les
bocks du cerveau à tel point qu'il ya
même des gens c'est devenu leur métier
de faire bugger nos cerveaux jory vivent
de ça c'est notamment le cas de hakim
que vous connais tous en tout cas vous
avez tous déjà vu passer une vidéo de
lui et qui ne fait que ça après je crois
qu'il ya pas mal d'effets spéciaux dans
ce qu'il fait mais il joue quand même
sur ton cerveau et ça fait beaucoup
d'efforts c'est un truc que j'adore
parce que on met toujours du temps à
voir les choses dans le bon sens entre
guillemets si je peux me permettre
et surtout c'est un truc qui
régulièrement créés sur les réseaux
sociaux des conflits énorme
les plus gros conflit qui a eu entre des
humains c'était à cause d'un problème de
perspectives et récemment sur les
réseaux sociaux sur twitter plus
particulièrement il ya une nouvelle
battle la battle de la balançoire les
gens se sont insultés menacés
je suis sûr il ya au moins deux
personnes deux personnes sur la planète
qui sont frappés à cause de la vidéo
tout simplement la vidéo extrêmement
simple voilà il ya quelqu'un au loin qui
fait de la balançoire et l'angle de vue
est tel que certaines personnes la voix
se balancer vers nous et d'autres la
voient se balancer vers le bâtiment
alors spoil elle se balance bel et bien
vers nous mais il est vrai qu'il ya un
moment dans la vidéo où on a
l'impression qu'elle va vers le bâtiment
et c'est assez troublant d'ailleurs
quand tu as réussi à voir les deux
perspectives différentes de voulait voir
s'enchaîner complètement pile au même
moment dans le mouvement c'est génial
est ce que j'adore c'est qu'il ya des
gens qui est vraiment qu il s'embrouille
à mort pour ce à quoi qui n'ont
malheureusement pas regarder la vidéo
qu'on a fait sur le saint bris des
perspectives et du coup il passe pour
des cons à se mettre sur la gueule ou à
la partager mes vidéos savons les gens -
course il faut vous aviez sûrement vu le
sud et la balançoire mais il ya une
deuxième battle mec depuis deux jours
après c'est celle des dauphins c'est un
mec qui filme sa homepage de ps4
il ya deux [ __ ] de dauphin sur l'écran
est le dilemme était le suivant
voyez-vous les dauphins de dos ou de
face je voulais simplement pour voir si
vous faites partie de la team de dos ou
de face
c'est faux je m'en fous
ce qui est génial c'est qu'encore une
fois les gens se frappe alors qu'il est
possible de voir les deux et vous pouvez
tout ce que le cir avoir les deux
regarde et je vous aide un peu hop là là
vous le voyez venir vers nous et là hop
là vous le voyez aller vers la bas du
coup j'ai fait quelques recherches pour
cette vidéo de trucs de perspectives un
peu drôle et j'ai découvert un truc que
je connaissais pas du tout un phénomène
scientifique au taps qu'ils reparlent un
phénomène scientifique attend des amis
scientifique it est pas la vidéo je vais
pas faire une pyramide 2 on n'est pas à
l'abri roma ça s'appelle l'écoulement
laminaire je n'interprète pas la
définition je la lis comme ça les padres
en mécanique des fluides l'écoulement
luminaires et le mode d'écoulement des
fluides ou l'ensemble du fluide s'écoule
plus ou moins dans la même direction
sans que les différences locales ce
contrat en gros c'est un jet d'eau mais
tu as l'impression qu'il est gelée qu'il
est en pause parce que la trajectoire de
l'eau est extrêmement riche ça y est je
suis en train d'interpréter la
définition est dit que de la merde alors
j'ai trouvé deux vidéos qui sont
spectaculaires à ce sujet la première
c'est celle ci film est d'en dessous
regardez on dirait que l'eau est gelée
que c'est un stack dit ou un stalag
mythe je sais plus la diff c'est
impressionnant en fait c'est juste le g
qui est parfaitement régulier ça y est
je suis en train de répliquer ce faire
exprès regardez quand même il va mettre
son doigt et on voit bel et bien que
c'est de l'eau en mouvement et non pas
de l'eau gelée complètement figé je
trouve ça fou ce phénomène maison du
monde ikea tout ça là si vous regardez
cette vidéo fait un objet de décoration
une fontaine qui reproduit cet effet là
ça sauf tranquillement à noël ça nous
retire une épine du pied up cadeau
facile est impressionnant et mahmoud en
fait la première vidéo qui a vraiment
marché qui montrait ce phénomène c'est
en 2010 elle avait fait un million de
vues et c'est encore plus impressionnant
parce que l'eau est encore plus
régulière avec commence à l'arrivée et
remonte et en fait c'est un truc qui
envoie de l'eau on dirait un tube en
verre
ces superbes ou quoi ça c'est de la
[ __ ] dos au mouvement mec grande
écoute je suis deg puisque j'ai jamais
pu observer ça de mes propres yeux dans
la dans la vie voilà je le vois qu en
vidéos regardées irene on dirait du
verre mec c'est dingue
j'espère tôt fait le même effet sinon je
me sens sale troisième vidéo qu'à
marcher de fou sur twitter là et qui est
sorti le même jour que la battle des
dauphins je sais pas ce qui s'est passé
en cinq jours là tout le monde a adoré
les perspectives sur la mecque
il m'a énervé tellement il est puissant
mais voulait peut-être déjà vu
[Musique]
j'étais stressée pour ce gars j'étais
stressée je me disais [ __ ] ils
arrivent vraiment vite l'arrêt comment
il va faire pour atterrir ce n'est pas
un gars c'est un jouet télécommandé en
plastique je regrette d'avoir eu de
l'empathie pour les [ __ ] et méritait
aucune empathie bordel allez passons
maintenant dans la phase de découverte
jeux content là je vous ai montré ce que
j'avais déjà vu maintenant on découvre
on s'en faisait partie le mur marchands
de la confusion
qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait c'est quoi à
wawa gentil ok ils ont chacun une jambe
blanche et une jambe noir qui rejoint
leurs voisins je déteste ça c'est fort
aux mecs
en fait on dirait qu au milieu de deux
gars qui vont bien il ya un gars qui va
pas bien et qui se balance comme ça
voyou bas jadore jadore jadore continuer
cas c'est moi ça me je ve qui fument à
la fin de cette ville où je veux qu'ils
fument à pop vous m'aurez pas ça je le
dis a vu plein de fois bah oui j'ai vu à
vendredi tout est permis quand j'étais
plus jeune il est dans un décor pencher
et la caméra aussi épanché donc on a
l'impression que tous tes droits mais on
connait tous avec ses plus vieux tricks
de l'humanité j'exagère chez youtuber
excusez moi y arriver là la fin bah
voilà ça oui alors boire ou ok j'ai
capté la colonne ne tourne pas mais
comme les gens descendent tous a à peu
près la même vitesse on a l'impression
que la colonne tournée que j'en ai assez
génial comme illusion j'applaudis quand
même l'architecte au cas où maison du
monde ikea si vous pouvez sortir son
appareil en objets de décoration je suis
chiant vous hanter que des problèmes de
déco lâchez moi ok ce gif gif je sais
pas comment on dit s'accélère quand vous
regardez ailleurs
ok on ne teste en ceinture
c'est probablement le meilleur moment de
la vidéo c'est quand je parle pas ça me
le fait un peu
ok mais je sais pourquoi c'est que quand
je regarde je regarde le perso au milieu
et pas les trucs sur les côtés la vision
périphérie allez-vous plus concentrés
sur les trucs que sur le même qu'au
milieu du coup je vais ouvrir une chaîne
où je parle de science je veux faire
trembler cette communauté scientifique
qui m'apprécient beaucoup déjà lapin ou
corbeau alors ce débat mais il peut du q
vous vous entendez bien aucun qu'une pub
plus que celui là ça n'a aucun sens mais
le débat c'est est ce que c'est un
oiseau ou un lapin
[Musique]
voilà là on atteint les limites du buzz
grâce à la perspective
oui ça peut créer des tweets et peur
virale mais ce n'est pas une raison pour
dire que ton corbeau et un lapin
stéphanie sera suffit alors mike use of
perspective aaa il en fallait aller on
est obligé on peut pas faire une vidéo
sur les perspectives sans montrer un
truc comme ça vous savez c'est classique
au couple objets au premier plan des
gens au second plan et les deux rend
parfaitement d'accord donc on aura pour
seul objet au premier plan et géant
alors que pas du tout il est pas mal et
ça pas celui-là il est sain par bus ils
le font en famille et tout bon mood
j'aime beaucoup ça marchera toujours ça
ces trucs là alors ça c'est hyper cool
c'est l'oeuvre d'un photographe qui
s'appelle bella borsodi est en fait il
n'y a pas quatre images il n'y en a
qu'une
il les a positionnés de manière à ce
qu'on croit que c'est un collage voilà
ça c'est le même décor mépris sous un
autre axe on se rend compte du taf que
ça demandait quand c'est hyper sympa non
vraiment sympa bravo huawei un taux qui
tombe là et autres qui tombe alors ok au
delà de l'illusion qui savait car [ __ ]
de camion pareil existe et qui est s'il
vous plaît tous les poteaux l'activation
des chantiers expliquez moi c'est quoi
ce camion mec assez encore science mag
elle tient ce match je vous ai vu c vous
l'académie la vidéo du parachute là déjà
ça veut pas surfer sur le buzz de la
balançoire et des dauphins au 1 vous
croyez avoir qu'il avoue nous aurait pas
nous en fait vous croyez quoi vous
croyez qu'on va vous êtes fous alors
jason pôle freelancing illusion à samedi
quelque chose
voilà ça j'adore ça c'est purement la
perspective trop fort
aa c'est trop bien tout est construit à
l'envers tout et glu est en fait le seul
les plafonds et les plafonds et le sol
et le cameraman filme à l'envers en fait
est juste après il retourne images voilà
parce que j'avoue pendant une minute je
me suis dit mais comment il fait le
caméraman lui il est collé au plafond
je suis un [ __ ] de bill the add on the
floor assez génial mec c'est une pub
pour un anti mites et puces pour chiens
le commercial mais légendaire col
mythique of anubis wow il existe
vraiment vous voyez les pyramides et
tout ça au je me tire des balles dans le
pied sans cesse ça j'ai envie de lui
parler à cette personne si elle existe
vraiment veut dire mec c'est fou on taxe
la rue parce que j'avais peut-être de
chiens s'efface quand même hyper pas qu
on commence 2020 déjà en roue libre
c'était watts et si je me fais
démonétisé pour ça salviac l'illusion et
olmèques genre ils ont même réussi à
[ __ ] le robot de youtube un an annoncé
génial c'est juste une photo très
rapprochés du dessus d'un poteau capoue
oui bah ça je suis sûr galerie dit et je
vais le trouver sur sa sur la macrophoto
on croit que c'est un truc en plan large
vue de loin et tout est en fait c'est
quelque chose de petit de très très haut
mais ça j'adore aussi bon après ça
rejoint carrément le thème des
perspectives mais c'est la macrophoto tu
photographies en très gros un truc très
petit et du coup tu as l'impression que
c'est quelque chose de très grands comme
la n va les mes explications sont
toujours nul après huit ans de youtube
c'est chiant quoi ça c'est une figure
qu'on peut voir tourner dans tous les
sens regardez là on a l'impression que
ça tourne dans le sens des aiguilles
d'une montre d'un coup hop ça tourne
verticalement et plus horizontalement
d'un coup c'est dans le sens des rats il
est horrible c'est l'objet qui cassent
tous un bon mec ah bah voilà belge dit
pas que des conneries il en a offert un
objet de décoration [ __ ] voilà je
savais bien c'est trop bien mais qu'est
de faire des objets de déco avec des
trucs d'illusions à la je suis refait la
mon ego ça fait du bien bon allez on
ramasse tous notre notre cerveau se
tuent sympa j'adore ce truc de
perspectives c'est vraiment génial et je
suis trop content qu'ils aient des
tweets qui arrive jusqu'à moi tellement
ils ont marché et qui traite de ça
justement de perspectives quand j'ai vu
tout de la balançoire j'étais comme un
oeuf j'adore s'il vous plaît continuez à
faire bugger nos cerveaux à jouer sur
les perspectives à faire croire à notre
cerveau que quelque chose existe
alors que pas du tout que ça vous a plu
je suis désolé si certains ont chopé un
petit mal de crâne entrée en fait ça
peut faire mal au crâne
je trouve ça fascinant comme notre
propre cerveau peut nous trahir nous
tromper j'adore ça va toujours plus
quand j'ai appris d'ailleurs ce qui
était un mirage je trouvais ça génial
c'est ouvrir c'est le pire facebook bref
merci d'avoir regardé je souhaite à tous
une autre bonne matinée après midi
soirée vous en foutez vous en foutez
cette fois c'est vous qui vous en citer
allez à bientôt
c'est yahoo
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]